hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the bogeyman as they
want to say in the UK lands so now it's
obviously raining which is gonna make it
a little bit harder to hear but also the
lightning can illuminate things unless
the lightnings gonna eliminate shadows
on the wall that make me think or
something no I don't like it when you're
hiding and then the closet is only the
second favorite place for the bogeyman
the second the first under the bed
everybody knows that I didn't want to
know that I mean to be perfectly honest
I don't even need to know if I need to
look down there for what was that oh god
David I need not waste my battery I
don't even know if I need to look down
there if I'm more rationing about my my
expenditure of my flashlights then I
should be okay I mean I did pretty good
in last one but I'm it I kept things but
admittedly it's probably a little bit
easier considering that this is the
beginning of the game and the more that
he the more that he comes out to play
what was that oh I see you it wasn't you
that made the noise no no oh hi thank
you
thank you for their wonderful rendition
of that song glad that happened now and
not during the day oh god they're making
a little bit more difficult because it's
hard to see with the clues er hi hi
good timing on the TV there I'm gonna
look under my bed thank you I think I
got something
oh oh I don't like this I don't like
this at all I can't see a goddamn thing
no that's right back off sassy sooo I
got to get that before he gets any
farther on that one next time because I
imagine if he can actually open the
window all the way it's gonna be bad for
me
I just got to be calm and collected and
everything's gonna be stopped that
you son of a sash you ass blasting sass
well well I was there before you even
got there
I heard that how you'd you slunk in your
claws along the corridors of the vents
that's what they're called I imagine I
don't know I'm just a child I wonder if
like even in the later nights if there's
still a possibility that he would be
down below the bed even after you
immediately get him because if there's a
4/20 mode in this game I imagine it's
gonna be pull out all the stops if
douchiness oh god I don't like this my
hand is cramping up I'm so tense ready
to move so it was bound to happen at any
moment or maybe not maybe I'm okay hey I
see you I'm ready
what was that what was that Bologna I'll
be pulling that bull with me come on man
you got to be nice to me my heart can't
take it okay
the Lightning illumination is nice every
once in a while oh that was outside I
heard like something zooming over my
head I thought it was in the geek I
don't know what that is
that's nothing shut up you stupid monkey
that's really annoying there but why is
my night no why is my night blindness
not working the same way that it was
before I was able to see a little better
before I can only do it over here why it
doesn't make any sense
that's the kitchen ah okay that was him
up there all right
no who's calling home where are the
parents
where's my mommy and my daddy I'm a UK
Brit I'm a Brit child no thank you
I'm okay actually I don't know what you
said but I'd rather have nothing to do
with it
okay hey that's right back off okay that
was cool was it the Frog all right then
do you think I just shut the window and
you think I just closed the door
but apparently I'm immobilized with fear
okay whoa whoa aah I didn't know what
that was at first yeah
the layers of noises the layers of
noises are starting to get pretty
distracting so I can only imagine this
is only night too so when it gets to
night three and four and five and
probably six and then seven tonight just
in case it's gonna get pretty bad why am
I still here why am I still sleeping in
the stupid house why would I stay again
like what's my nights a phrase why would
you stay what is it oh why would you
stay when everything is screaming at you
to leave I'm not even making any money
I'm a child
hello whoo whoo I'm a child I need not
work a minimum-wage job of house-sitting
huh I'm just doing this to survive all
right almost time for cuckoo time cuckoo
clock Hey
okay cuckoo I gotta be cuckoo if I'm
staying in this house I'm gonna carry
under the third night tells us that was
a quick one I did that without incident
okay so okay everything's a-okay in this
department I'm doing good I'm doing real
good
nine three okay how tough could it be
not very I imagine okay so that light's
still on but I guess it goes off in the
night who is that on the table is that
my mama so my mama is that my mommy mama
oh boy a fog roll
we check on the bed for me oh sure I'm
too tired
total sleep I can't sleep
what if he's under there fine I'll check
it if it makes you stop pestering me see
nothing
peep she's under your bed Alice yeah
well he'll help me hey you're too easy
to scare Alice yet
now go to sleep otherwise I'll say the
words that make him [ __ ] he's dumb
I'll go to sleep what's that what's that
was it hi what are you doing
that's a dysfunctional family if I ever
heard one all right so this son of a
[ __ ] is gonna be a little more eager
and there's a fog rolling in for now
said nope oh he's being much more eager
this time okay good check for better
don't be under there yeah that's what I
felt oh boy what is it no no five nights
at freddy squawks oh god the Frog the
frogs out okay frog is done apparently
frogs taking a breather nope
I said no I said a whole lot of nope
there's gonna be a more eventful night I
can already tell but I know I can get
through what it's just darkness hey none
of that I'm just gonna stay over here
where it actually lights up so that the
people watching at home could actually
see something oh no they can't actually
see something anymore I'll just look at
the vent then I guess so that the guys
at home can actually see something
really dark I can mean that could look
out the window I guess I should look out
the window right now hello sure is good
of you to cover up everything that I'm
trying to not none of that none of that
none of that exactly none of that douche
nozzle
shut up shop I see up there no no no no
no nights me for one I'm a child I got
like no Meetup no meat on my bones
you gotta go find someone else man
because I'm not I'm not your pick
I'm not your prey I'm not the ideal I'm
the opposite bimba no shut up shut up
shut up petite up hey whoa whoa hey okay
didn't know a god I need to be better
about the sounds because otherwise he's
going to come and kill me nope you
creepy crawly with the freaking closet
that always happens why does that
surprise me
nope whoosh I got plenty of battery I'm
gonna do hain but I got it probably
later on in the nights be a loop what is
that whoa hey now whoa what was that
okay so now I'm getting a little night
night vision there Oh cuz it got bright
outside oh god damn it stop that no no
no and Oh
no no with your stupid creepy-crawly
this game makes a lot of good use of
light and sound which I do appreciate in
horror games but not right now okay okay
that is awfully nice
wait gives me thanks buddy thanks pal
you're a doll I'm hearing noises in like
real life it's throwing me off god it's
really hey none of that
you stupid creep it coolly not creepy
crit creepy crawly creepy cruelly sorry
I got a British accent I'm British
seems like I'm gonna be doing okay for
this whoa whoa whoa okay what the hell
is that stuff it's not okay dude can't
be doing combo noises it's not fair I
don't need to look under my bed I'm
gonna be fine it's 4:40 and there's
plenty of time left in the night I'm
gonna be a-okay I'd be a-okay I imagine
that the last light to go out in this
game won't the night's progress it's
gonna be the night out there light out
there light night out there night light
out there late night out there okay all
good
Hey oh well there goes the night lip
goes the light night out there oh the
night light out there but I still can
see a little bit which is awfully nice
but now it just means a scraggly closet
nope I see scraggly claws everywhere I
go I can't see a goddamn thing stop that
you monkey bastard nope
thank you okay 525 I think that says is
good plenty of time plenty of battery
plenty of time plenty of battery plenty
of time plenty of battery hey no come on
Oh plenty of time plenty of battery I
mean maybe you could get through all
these nights without needing a single
bit if you don't waste any of your light
on
extraneous uses or anything more than it
needs cuz he only needs like a quick
flash and then he's done so if I could
just get out of that then I'd be fine
and 550 yep oh here we go yay I done dit
yay I'm a winner baby okay so that was
the end of the third night this is going
much easier than I thought it would be
because I remember you know just me in
my five nights at Freddy's mode I'm
ready for everything to be absolutely
horrible and I didn't mention but this
game is on Steam and it is for sale and
it does cost money but so far what I've
seen so far it is pretty good boat I'll
reserve final judgment till I get later
in the game thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always don't see you
in the next video